>> Jesse: MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> Jesse: THE CRIME WAVE JUST
GOT PERSONAL.
NOPE, I WASN'T ASSAULTED.
MY NOSE JUST LOOKS LIKE THIS.
BUT I WAS VIOLATED.
THE PEACE AND SANCTITY OF MY
IDYLLIC UPPER SIDE WAS.
I HAVE SEVERAL CELEBRITY
NEIGHBORS INCLUDING ALL OF ME
WERE TARGETS ALL OF US COULD BE
TARGETED AT ANY TIME.
I WAS RETURNING FROM MY PHYSICAL
THERAPY APPOINTMENT IN THE ADD
STRONG OF REPORTERS OUTSIDE A
TOWN HOUSE AROUND THE CORNER
FROM MY PLACE.
WHAT WAS THIS ABOUT, I THOUGHT
TO MYSELF?
WHICH CELEBRITY NEIGHBOR OF MINE
WERE THEY STAKING OUT?
WAS IT SPIKE LEE?
WAS IT AL SHARPTON?
S WOULD IT RAMONA FROM THE REAL
HOUSEWIVES?
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE I WRIGLEY
SEE OUT AT ITALIAN RESTAURANTS
OR WAITING IN LINE AT THE
PHARMACY.
I WILL LET YOU GUESS OHIO
USUALLY SEE WAITING IN LINE FOR
THEIR PRESCRIPTION.
IN FACT, RICKY GERVAIS PET
ROOKIED OTHER DAY WHILE EMMA WAS
WALKING HIM.
THESE ARE THE CASUAL TYPE OF
CELEBRITY INTERACTIONS THAT YOU
LEARN TO TAKE FOR GRANTED.
THE INNOCENCE OF MY HUMBLE
STOMPING GROUND WAS TAKEN FROM
ME WHEN I HEARD THE NEWS.
>> IN NEW YORK CITY THERE IS N
NEWS THIEWS EVENING INVOLVING
ACTOR ROBERT DENIRO THE BREAK-IN
AT HIS HOME OVERNIGHT.
>> Jesse: ROBERT DENIRO, THOSE
OF US WHO SEE HIM AROUND TOWN WE
JUST CALL HIM BOBBY WAS KIND OF
LIKE FAMILY.
HAD I EVER BEEN TO HIS TOWN
HOUSE?
NO.
DID I EVEN KNOW HE LIVED THERE
AT ALL?
NO.
IN FACT I WAS HURT THAT HE NEVER
SEEN ME AT THE BAKERY AND
INVITED ME OVER.
I THEN LEARNED DENIRO DIDN'T OWN
THE TOWN HOUSE RENTING IT FOR A
MERE $70,000 A MONTH.
YOU WOULD THINK A PLACE LIKE
THAT WOULD HAVE BETTER SECURITY.
IT'S ABOUT AS INSECURE AS PAULIE
P.'S TOWN HAAS APPOINTLY.
PERHAPS LESS.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER IF DENIRO
WAS HOME.
WHICH HE WAS, HE WAS SLEEPING
UPSTAIRS.
HOW DID THE TOUGHEST ACTOR IN
HOLLYWOOD HANDLE THE BREAK-IN?
I DON'T KNOW, MUCH TO MY
SURPRISE WE LEARNED THAT DENIRO
NEVER WOKE UP.
THE NYPD ARRESTED THE ROBBER
WHILE HE WAS RUMMAGING THROUGH
CHRISTMAS PRESENTS FOUND
FUMBLING WITH iPAD.
DENIRO'S DAUGHTER WAS HOME AT
THE TIME.
THIS HAPPENED AROUND 2:30 IN THE
MORNING.
IF ROBERT DENIRO ISN'T SAFE?
NO ONE IS SAFE.
WHO'S NEXT?
JEAN-CLAUDE VAN DAMME GOING TO
GET PICKPOCKETTED?
WHERE DOES THIS END?
LUCKILY POLICE WERE ON THE SCENE
AND SAW THE BURGLAR BREAKING IN
AND CAPTURED HER IN THE ACT.
THAT'S RIGHT, HER.
THIS IS THE FACE OF AMERICA'S
CRIME WAVE.
CHANISE EMALES.
THIS WAS IN THE HER FIRST BREAK
IN.
OUT ON BAIL FROM A ROBBERY
COMMITTED TWO WEEKS AGO.
THANKS TO THE LOVELY BAIL REFORM
PACKAGE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
PASSED.
THIS CLEPTO WAS RAGING A WAR ON
CHRISTMAS THROUGHOUT NEW YORK
CITY.
NOT ONLY PILFERING PRESENT UNDER
CELEBRITY'S TREES PINCHING
CHURCH DONATIONS DURING SUNDAY
MASS.
THIS YEAR ALONE SHE HAS BEEN
BUSTED 16 TIMES FOR BURGLARY.
CHANISE HAS BEEN ARRESTED 26
TIMES IN TOTAL.
HERE IS CHANISE IN HER OWN
WORDS.
>> CHANISE, ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
SAY TO YOUR SON.
>> I DIDN'T MURDER ANYBODY.
>> ANYBODY YOU WANT TO SAY.
>> DID YOU GO INTO ROBERT
DENIRO'S HOUSE?
>> I DIDN'T GO IN ROBERT
DENIRO'S HOUSE.
>> TECHNICALLY SHE IS RIGHT ON
BOTH COUNTS.
SHE DID NOT MURDER ANYBODY AND
WAS NOT ROBERT DENIRO'S HOUSE.
HE WAS RENTING IT.
BUT THIS IS THE POINT.
IF THIS WASN'T RAGING BULL'S
TOWN HOUSE, WE WOULDN'T HAVE
KNOWN ABOUT CHANISE.
YOU DON'T HEAR ABOUT ALL THE
CRIMES THAT ARE COMMITTED
AGAINST REGULAR PEOPLE.
PRODUCER TOLD ME ABOUT HER
BROTHER WHO WAS MUGGED WHY A
GANG OF TEENS.
THEY APPROACHED HIM, ACTING LIKE
THEY WERE ARMED.
YOU KNOW, THE OLD FINGER IN THE
POCKET MOVE, AND DEMANDED MONEY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY MONEY BUT HE
JUST HAD GOTTEN BACK FROM THE
DELI.
ALL HE HAD ON HIM WAS AN ITALIAN
SUB.
THEY TOOK 9 SUB, BY FORCE, AND
HE WENT HOME WITHOUT DINNER.
LOCAL NEWS DIDN'T COVER IT.
ABC DIDN'T EVEN TOUCH IT.
BUT "PRIMETIME" DOES.
BECAUSE, TO US, THERE'S NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ROBERT DEN DO
AND MY PRODUCER'S HUNGRY
BROTHER.
WHETHER CHRISTMAS PRESENTS,
ITALIAN SUBS OR DONATION BOXES,
ALL CRIMES ARE CREATED EQUAL.
MY NEIGHBORHOOD IS FOREVER
CHANGED BECAUSE THIS HIT SO
CLOSE TO HOME AND BECAUSE I'M SO
DEDICATED I VISITED THE CRIME
SCENE OF MY GOOD FRIEND BOBBY
TODAY.
HERE I AM PUTTING DOWN SOME SHOE
LEATHER.
I'M STANDING EXACTLY WHERE
CHANISE STOLED BEFORE THIS
LITTLE FAULKER STARTED BREAKING.
IF DENIRO HAD BEEN AWAKE, I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> PIECE OF CAKE OFFERING.
>> SORRY.
COME ON, MAN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THEY CAME FOR BOBBY.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD IS NOT SAFE FOR
WATERS WOR